I have this theory that the World
Economic Forum which is historic in
committed to improving the state to the
world brings all these leaders into one
place and it tells them hey together we
can do anything you want here like we
are health we are politically which we
have billions of dollars and we can look
at the problems in the world and solve
the problems of the world and who is
that just go away that's me there
everyone has lived through last crisis
is looking at the neighbors coming to us
like this unstoppable train and they say
oh my god and we apply them right now is
how earthly trying jump out of the way
of this train is there any way we can
hedge these risks probably not by the
way you know if the train has hit ten
hits you and there's nothing you can
really do about it and the amount of
ridiculous hubris and overconfidence but
somehow the people here on top of us
without somewhere can get together and
either stop the train or like the
mitigators impact I'm not hearing that
anywhere at all everyone is very
resigned to their kind of P how this
awesome I think this is new feeling I've
never clearly felt here and that was
before normally people very close
themselves and I think this is the year
of modesty when people wake up and
realize they have no control we saw this
last year with it with the Arab Spring
we know here we were like talking away
you know amongst each other while the
real news was happening completely out
of our control in Egypt and and now the
real news is happening completely out of
our control in Europe Nev know is all of
the Europeans that here it's like
there's nothing we can do all we can do
is watch